hello and welcome i'm james murphy from
m coding
and today we're going to be talking
about the def main if name main idiom
in python and why you should be using it
in all of your scripts
first off not every file is a script by
a script i mean a file that you intend
to run
not a library so something like this
that just defines a function that you're
supposed to import in another file
is not going to benefit from this idiom
most languages like c plus or java
have a kind of boilerplate setup that
you need to write
even to write the most basic function
java is notorious for having its public
static void mainstream args
as one of the first things that a
programmer sees before learning to use
it
but in python it's seemingly a lot
simpler all you need to do is say print
hello world
but what i hope to convince you of by
the end of this video is that you should
really prefer
this def main if name main idiom over
just writing things out in a line
okay really quickly if you're not
familiar what is this name variable
if you run the script from your terminal
or elsewhere you'll see that the
name variable turns out to be this
double underscore main double underscore
but if you import the file you see
something different
in this case we see the double
underscore name is if name main package
dot
import me to print name
the difference in behavior allows you to
check whether the file is being run as a
script or not
if you see dunder main then it's being
run as a script
and if it's anything else then it's
being imported
you could just stop there and put all
the statements that you want to execute
when this is run as a script
into this if block but i say you should
go one step further and
define it as a main function
okay so you can check whether or not
your code is being run as a script or
being imported
but why why would you want to do this
is it just a way to flex on programmers
that don't know the idiom or is there a
reason for actually doing this
well yes of course there are reasons for
doing it let's go over them
the first and most important reason
actually has nothing to do with the
language itself
and everything to do with how people use
it
yes you can use if name main to check
whether or not your code is being run
versus imported
but this isn't what it signals to the
person reading your code
ifname main is used to signal that this
file is a script and you can run it
if i look at a file and i don't see
ifname main
i assume that i cannot or should not try
to run it
it makes me think it's supposed to be a
library or that it's only meant to be
imported
nothing about the python language
actually enforces this
but compare it to using an underscore as
a variable name
if you see an underscore in someone's
code they're basically saying
i'm not going to use this variable
nothing stops them from using it
but if they do use it they're kind of
breaking an
unspoken rule in the python community
underscore means i'm not going to use
this variable
and if name main means this is a script
don't keep your reader guessing if this
is supposed to be an entry point to your
program just make it explicit
many editors like pycharm use this as a
signal you can see
the file on the left has this green
arrow which says run hello
but there's no green arrow on the right
that's because pycharm knows the signal
if name main means this is something
that i want to run
no if name main means this is probably a
library you're not meant to just run it
but why should you extract main out into
a function instead of just leaving the
contents in the if block
here's a script that just defines some
function and then uses it to compute
something
even if i put this code inside a name
guard everything that i do here is still
in the global scope
in particular this variable i is a
global variable even if i didn't really
mean it to be that
suppose i define a function to compute
some value and then
later on i use it here i'm just trying
to add up some evaluations of this
function based off of this list
but i have accidentally made a typo
i use the variable i here but the name
of the loop variable was n
when i run the code instead of getting
an error for my typo
i silently get the wrong value this is
one of the worst kind of errors that you
can have
and this is all just within the same
file imagine if this happened in a
different file
if in another file or at the console i
do an import star of the bad script
i now have a global variable i that i
didn't know about
so if it was this file that defined the
compute valve function
this file now has a global variable i
and it's even harder than in the last
example to find this typo
also in the case where you didn't have
an if name main at all
just importing the script will actually
run it
that basically means that it's
impossible to test your code without
side effects
also note that there are plenty of cases
where importing your code happens
automatically
this script explicitly imports the
useful class from the bad script
and then writes it to a pickle file it's
clear here that we're importing the bad
script because we explicitly wrote it
but in this script there's no mention of
the bad script all we're doing is
unpickling some object we don't even
know where it came from
and yet when we run this code we see
that we did in fact import the bad
script
and run all of the code that was in its
body
this is because pickle.load
automatically imported the bad script
in order to get the definition of the
useful class in the pickle case it was
just a little bit annoying to have that
extra stuff printed out
but in this case we're doing some
multi-processing
the goal is to compute the values of
this useful function over some list of
inputs
multiprocessing pool is going to start
up a bunch of different python processes
that all automatically import this file
but without an if name main you can see
how this starts to get into trouble
just importing the file starts up new
processes
which then import the file and so on so
you pretty much
can't use multi-processing in this case
look what happens
and i can't even kill it with control c
i have to kill the terminal
putting this code in an if name main
prevents the rampant process spawning
but again without putting this in a
separate function this is now going to
give me a global variable named p
all you have to do to avoid this
headache is just use the idiom it's not
that much typing
and in fact you could probably just set
up your editor to have it there
automatically when you make a new file
or just have a template to paste it when
you type main
one final less used reason for making a
main function
is that this allows you to have an entry
point to your program that you can use
from other scripts
so i don't have to run this from the
command line i could import this from
another file
and then call the main function as if i
was running it from the command line
without starting a new process
in this case you can have your main take
in whatever arguments as an optional
parameter
alright that's all i've got on the deaf
main if name main idiom
let me know if you found any other
reasons to use it
also let me know if you're a hold out
what your reasons are for not using it
as usual thanks to my patrons and to my
donors for supporting me
if you liked the video don't forget to
subscribe and hit the like button
see you next time
you